with no rope Bay hints the Stars don't have their
full arsenal but as we mentioned off the top still
a very dangerous one up and down the lineup it's
taken by the blues and they will turn in here's
Brandon side he shot rung iron as he turned the
corner on Yanni hackin paaw mid-season form him
already for the folks here Stars don't clear
kyou has space attack here for St Louis KY
with a shot save made by aner all that off the
failed clearance and aner bailed it out with an
inti stop little over eight minutes gone by loose
Pucket Center that's Lindell he'll free it up a
shot Bennington the save and it just trickled into
the crease and would not have enough momentum Joe
pavelski that close stars on the attack looking
for a buzzer beater ryot johnon Feats it the donov
curling Shen comes out of the box shot Johnston
score Marchman was in front he may have gotten
a piece I always go by the emphatic nature of the
celebration and Marchman celebrated like the goal
scorer on that one I think it ticked off of his
stick in front just a simple ladder play between
dadonov and then Johnston and and then all alone
in front of the net just prior to that marchment
was wide open to the flank of Johnston when he
ripped one toward the net extremely offside in
a playoff game right and yeah and uh they had the
vote amongst the general managers to have review
for this upon video review the play was deemed to
be offside therefore we have no goal the league
got gets a stick comes across and it's even
though it's in the air the Stars thought they
had scored the first goal of the game with a
dozen seconds to go on the redirection from
Mason marchment but successful offside Challenge
from Craig barui and the blues holded it off the
board and we are scoreless to start the second
diving pass by Ben to get it off to Johnston
now delandria Ben the wrap around he shot scor
[Music] it's the captain Jamie Ben who opens the
scoring th this is Dallas Stars foreing
little dive nudge to make sure they enter
the zone Great play on the boards
by delandria coming hard down on
the rightwing side they get the St Louis
Blues in their defensive posture swimming
a little bit and James on the forehead Puck
on his stick leaves it for Hayes gets it back
to the line Tucker his shot hit bodies
in front of Aer now back for Tucker he
scores Tucker from the high slot
the shot low pass doer and a quick
answer by the blues to tie the game at one first
offering goes aai off of bodies right in front of
Jake ainger and Vera recks it for him screenshot
boy both defensemen both hackin paaw and essel
andell went out there to try to eat the puck
and it ends up working its way right through
and that's that's a wall of humanity visually
for rottinger to try to appearer through and
a perfectly placed shot pass the screen levels
the game at one now Sean pulls away from pressure
Banks it to hkin walks the line reot bounces save
rebound and Bennington robs Peli play by Joe
pavelski he goes in behind the net recognizes
where it's going spins off the defenseman comes
back out it in front to make himself available
for the deflection first and then the puck comes
clean straight to him and Bennington stares it
off of his left toe and then robs him this is
burglary in tight on pavelski flip pass back in
the St Louis Zone but then kyou almost turned it
over in a dangerous spot wound up doing so Smith
in front for Sean and Bennington was out able
to get the glove on it before Sig could turn
and regain possession thought you were going to
say he was going to fight TMX there it's better
he's going to find TM barbecue yes but he's going
to find TMX we chatted about that a shot saved by
AER a good one on the Fly by redirection and it's
just turnover at one end chance at the other at
times in this tilt tonight mat dude Shane high
slot left circle now in tight save benington
left leg on Johnston and a distant shot couldn't
get through for ainger to jump across and make
the save and then at the other end in tight
nice slick playmaking by Harley immediately
off the blade of Johnston and left pad larsy by
Jordan Bennington great goal tending low scoring
Sean and Shen at the dotted Center and we're
underway in the third Paro help start it in
Andre drifts and then feeds it off for Harley
right corner referee was nearby that was a
problem for Thomas and the Stars will escape
Neil's lanquist step to the inside nice move
list shot off the bar GLS side on Bennington
he hit it [Applause] flush that d Shane he's
got 10 career overtime goals in the regular
season Kyler San is out there with him also
at 10 lose control it first in front and
rolls in on AER what a chance for Faulk
to never settle it then how underneath the
stick and Andrew's got to come clean it up
bump it ahead to B the stars break in it's hin
in a step save Bennington the theater back in
session Stars control here they come delayed call
Stars have numbers hin in right side Robertson sa
bennington's magic act continued you want hinan
and Robertson I think that puck flipped a little
bit it's great Patience by ML hkin and to hold it
hold it he's trying to hold Bennington he's trying
to hold the defenseman last minute he slides
it across but Bennington in Larsen's fashion
gets across cross and Stones them right from the
draw off they go the two guys you want hinan and
Robertson I think that puck flipped a little bit
Ben in the trapezoid centers Robertson pass can't
connect and the stars on the short time on the
power play had some looks could not bury out of
the one hole is Jason Robertson five for seven
last year he's usually the leadoff man in on
Bennington Robertson brilliant on the backend
he makes it look so easy and it's not you can
see Bennington try to stay as patient as humanly
possible but he out Waits him and then shovels a
back hand a lot of times he just flips that for
hand over the glove this time an extra tick same
result brated Shen is the first shooter on tinger
Shen quickly and he beats AER stick side quick
answer in round one for St Louis hot had the right
idea he comes out to take shot away but he backed
in maybe retreated a little too quickly froze on
it expecting a shot and a perfectly placed off the
bar and in so duchaine five for seven last year
with the PRS second shooter duchaine scores the
top two guys Flawless for Dallas fantastic through
overtime [Applause] gorgeous stuff from duch Shane
Jordan Kyu their leading score from a year ago to
extend the game kyou lost the puck and the stars
hold they come out to greet AER 18,500
standing Dallas wins it 2-1 on opening night